[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEAN YOU: Our company is
a leading mobility service
provider here in South Korea.
And our user base is more
than 30 million users,
which means most people in
South Korea use our services.
Our DevOps philosophy is to
detect and recover the failure
as fast as we can.
Since our ride-hailing service
and [INAUDIBLE] services
are so critical to our users,
we put relentless effort
to achieve zero downtime.
Therefore, our
DevOps team mainly
focuses on improving the
detectability of system
failures and designing
[INAUDIBLE] systems that
can recover automatically.
So in this project, we wanted
to re-architecture our systems
so that we can operate
our microservices,
both in our [INAUDIBLE] Cloud
and Google Cloud Platform
simultaneously.
The first objective was to
build an environment that
can respond to the heavy
[INAUDIBLE] traffic.
In case of the sudden
traffic increases,
we were able to acquire
additional resources in Google
Cloud Platform very
smoothly instead
of acquiring on-prem resources.
So I think the future growth is
order of kind of two or three
times in terms of traffic
and then the kind of service
we need to provide in
terms of your growth.
So that would be
huge if you think
about the amount of
traffic we handle today.
Additional resources
were required.
So we rebalanced the traffic
so that a large amount
of on-prem traffic could be
processed in Google Cloud
Platform.
The past increase, according
to the HPA settings in the GKE,
based on the number of
cores in GCP resources--
it increased about four
times compared to the usual.
And it increased from the
previously set quota, 20%,
to about 80%.
Our project team's capability
have grown together
with Google teams enduring
support, especially customer,
engineer, and technical
account managers.
There is bi-weekly regular
meeting with our DevOps team,
GCP team, and GCP's partner.
GCP customer success
manager has taken
care of all the required GCP
learning classes we needed.
Also, it becomes a unique
differentiated point
to talk about a long-term
perspective roadmap
and further collaboration
point between GCP and us.
Under the strong support
from the Google Cloud team,
we were able to expedite
a work in progress
to get into stable
first migration to GCP.
It was a very
pleasant experience
to work together as a team.
And I expect more collaboration
in this year as well.
Project was very challenging
for our DevOps team,
since we only have
used on-prem cloud.
Learning new
technologies as well as
operating seamlessly between
two different infrastructures
was very difficult.
And migrating
the new architecture-- migrating
to the new architecture
with zero service downtime
was very challenging as well.
However, thanks to the support
from the Google Cloud Korea
team, we were able to
migrate the service smoothly.
And we were very happy with
the successful migration.
[MUSIC PLAYING]